so we've got to get back to this.
Anthony Foushee story yesterday.
In 24 hours, this has completely exploded.
Yesterday, I told you that increasingly Donald
Trump is listening to people other than doctors.
I guess we would say Dr. Anthony Foushee,
the chief infectious disease doctor of the
United States who's been working with presidents
for 40 years in the United States, worked
on the AIDS epidemic, et cetera, et cetera.
Dr. Foushee revealed that he had not even
spoken to Donald Trump for what now would
be about five weeks and that he is not briefed
Donald Trump on coronavirus in a serious manner
for two months.
I also told you yesterday that the White House
has put out a list of things that Foushee
got wrong in order, I guess, to discredit
him.
So clearly it was going bad.
Meanwhile, Donald Trump has retweeted Chuck
Woolery.
And this is continuing to escalate.
I'll get to the Woolery thing momentarily.
But in just the 24 additional hours since
yesterday's show, there now seems to be a
war.
This is crazy.
Not between the White House and the virus.
That's the war.
If you want to apply war language here.
It should be us versus the virus.
There seems to be a war between the White
House and the government's own top infectious
disease, Dr. Anthony Foushee.
Foushee just seems to be doing medical stuff
and the world is again crying and laughing
because the White House is going after, not
the virus.
They're going after Foushee.
Dr. Foushee.
Good for him.
Is no longer mincing words.
He said very clearly the reason cases are
exploding is because we never completely shut
down and we're doing the wrong things.
States that really came down were fully shut
down and stayed closed longer.
Others opened too early.
Here's the full quote from Dr. Foushee.
We did not shut down entirely.
And that's the reason why we went up.
We started to come down and then we plateaued
at a level that was really quite high.
About 20000 infections a day.
Then as we started to reopen, we're seeing
the surges that we're seeing today as we speak.
We made a set of guidelines a few months ago.
Unfortunately, it did not work very well for
us.
We can get a handle on that.
I am really confident we can, if we step back,
understand that to avoid having to fully shut
down again, which it looks like some states
are starting to do.
You have to pull back for a while.
You have to really limit things.
What is going to turn around the case explosion
in Arizona, Texas, California and Florida.
If you don't shut now, it shut down.
California has extended a shut down to 30
counties now, including L.A. County, in six
weeks.
Hopefully, we will see the positive effect
of that.
It takes a while.
These other states are barely doing a thing.
What will turn it around?
The heat hasn't turned it around.
You know, whatever else they said was going
to turn it around has not.
Meanwhile, instead of working with Dr. Foushee,
the White House is now fully on the offensive
against Dr. Foushee, the guy who worked 40
years under Republican and Democratic presidents
whose ideology is health.
He is the target of Trump's attack.
He is the target of the White House.
His opposition research.
The White House released a document to media
outlets meant to make Dr. Foushee look untrustworthy
with a list of things Foushee got wrong.
Notice Trump got wrong in April.
In March, actually, we have fifteen cases,
which will soon be zero.
Foushee is reportedly referred to by some
at the White House as Dr. Doom and Gloom.
Apparently, Foushee is not a pleasant enough.
About one hundred and forty thousand people
dying.
Foushee isn't upbeat about 60 to 70 thousand
new cases a day.
Another report alleges that Donald Trump is
reportedly rattled by the fact that the country
continues to trust Dr. Foushee more than they
trust Trump on coronavirus.
You know, we talk about ignorance in this
country a lot.
The country doesn't seem so ignorant that
they would trust the reality show host president
over Dr. Foushee on matters of infectious
disease.
And part of this is we know Trump doesn't
like anybody else getting positive attention,
but it gets even crazier because Donald Trump's
director of social media, Danske Corvino,
posted a pejorative cartoon about Dr. Foushee
that refers to him as Dr. Fosset.
Dr. Fosset, who wants to.
Turn off the faucet on everything, so to speak.
So they're essentially attacking Dr. Foushee,
I guess, because he's being too cautious.
Essentially, the White House seems to be attacking
Dr. Foushee for not being more fun, about
140000 U.S. deaths, a number that in all likelihood
in the next few days is going to start accelerating
more quickly, as we saw it do during the weekdays
last week.
The White House has gone to war not with the
virus, but with the doctor fighting the virus.
So what I suggest.
What I think we have to do is we have to step
back here and recognize that this is part
of the end to an anti intellectual ism in
this country where you can only trick the
population into continuing to just live a
completely normal life, as if nothing is going
on when you have a lot of uneducated and uninformed
and ignorant people.
And while on the one hand, it's good that
Dr. Foushee is still more trusted than Trump
because the virus spreads virally, even if
only 15, 20, 25, 30 percent of the country
thinks it's fine to just do whatever the hell
you want.
That's enough to perpetuate one of the worst
trajectories when it comes to cases in the
world.
Now, secondly, the idea that we've just had
too much shut down, we can't tolerate it anymore.
Recall that many states never shut down fully
because there was no national shut down, Trump
insists.
Oh, I shut it down and now I'm opening it
back up.
Trump never shut it down.
It was states that decided what they had to
do and many of them barely shut down.
We might now actually need a national shutdown
if things don't turn around.
We're going to talk also later today about
Trump's failings in terms of polling in Texas.
But once again, this could have been a political
windfall for Donald Trump.
He just had to say, listen, we're in it together,
listen to the doctors.
It's going to be tough.
But this is what we have to do.
I trust the doctors.
Let's do what they say.
We'd be better off.
Fewer people would have died.
Donald Trump would be cruising to reelection
right now.
Very different scenario.
Five months into Corona virus that we actually
see.
And now Donald Trump has been relegated to
retweeting conspiracy theories from game show
hosts.
Let's talk about
that next.